youtube this is a very very very special
episode of overrated underrated
because drock said so hey everybody this
is overrated underrated with me
[Music]
garyvee
all right so this is unusual episode
drock because
we've had some dinner i've drank some
wine
this could be an interesting episode
let's get into it uh
spin drift salter oh god i'm a big
spindrift guy it's actually
natural juice i'm obsessed my dad
grew up grew up really hot on sparkling
water in like the 80s when it wasn't as
common
so i'm a seltzer club soda sparkling kid
to begin with i consume it at scale
i think spin drift is underrated funko
i'm not into them but i love flip life i
love
pop culture i love collectibles i'm
gonna go with overrated
it's over supply to target right now it
feels not that culturally relevant
it still has some heat there are people
that are hardcore about it
i don't know just i feel like it was
overproduced ethereum
ethereum's crazy underrated nft is going
to be an acronym a lot of you are going
to be talking about
so i'll just leave it at that next
travis scott i think travis scott is
underrated i think he is
such a savvy creator
artist entrepreneur savvy underrated
everything every time i hear cash app
all i think about is robbie rich
properly rated i think it's very popular
ben mo cash
like properly read twitter
twitter spaces has my attention you know
what will be one of the fun social media
content
attention debates of 2021 is
was twitter spaces their move what
instagram did to snapchat instagram came
out with stories and stopped the hyper
momentum
of snap to snaps credit they took that
punch in the face they got up off the
canvas
innovated and are an incredible spot
right now snap
was already an established platform for
many years clubhouse is a baby
it's on fire but spaces has the
potential to
show that clubhouse is a feature like
stories is
unbelievably interesting for me twitter
spaces right now
underrated because i think 98 of the
audience that's watching this right at
the second has no idea what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about
cbd overrated i think cbd
is overrated because every consumer
products like
cbd but for me that's like saying this
has sugar
it's like a standardized thing and i
think a lot of entrepreneurs are still
like
check out my cbd thing i'm like bro that
ship has sailed that was five years ago
if you're gonna play that card
it's now standard it's a cost of entry
it's an ingredient
uh overrated amazon amazon
grossly underrated literally amazon inc
only vulnerability is the government
teddy bears teddy bears
me and aj were garage sailing one day
back in the day
and we bought stuffed animals we
realized that
stuffed animals were in arbitrage they
were easy to find
they were 25 cents to a dollar max and
they were consistently like
tons of them were 10 to 25 gunned
gu nd is a teddy bear company stiff is
the real [ __ ] but
i'll go into guy gunned we bought a
sailor
gunned stuffed animal for 10 cents we
listed for 99 cents
i'll never forget this i was going on a
wine buying trip to napa
getting on the plane aj calls me old
cell phones not smartphones pre
nokia and he goes like crazy excitement
he's like bro like what what i thought
it was a jets or knicks thing
he goes our sailor bear gunned
is at 90
i lost my mind this 10 cents to 90
is like more exciting than selling rezzy
for hundreds of millions of dollars or
empathy or like
like the most exciting i land drock
cause no wi-fi in planes
in napa six hours later 386
wow for that reason teddy bears are
underrated
that's a good question i'm gonna say
properly rated incredible infrastructure
absolutely as a business model building
similar things to
google and uh and the wine's hitting me
a little bit what's the restaurant i
mean rezzy literally disrupted it
open table in the early 2000s when you
typed a restaurant open table showed up
first
you'd go there then you'd go to the
restaurant they would charge the
restaurant a dollar they became a
tollbooth
zillow toll booth travelocity tollbooth
doordash is really a toll booth right
all these restaurants are using it but
doordash has the customers info
they have the relationship we're going
through doordash to
johnny's spaghetti shop those are big
businesses
i think doordash is underrated airpods
airpod max
underrated airpods are the only good
thing apple's done in 15 years
dave hippell underrated and he's
super rated i just think dave's smart as
[ __ ]
i think if you pay very close attention
to this comedy it's extremely smart
it's extremely sharp it's incredible
social commentating i resonate with it i
think i put out business content that
kind of sneakily is talking about life
he does the same thing with comedy even
with all the accolades that he's getting
i'm gonna go with under [ __ ] rated
whiskey's so hot
brown goods are so on fire now you know
a pap a bottle of pappy is like [ __ ]
a bitcoin or a jordan rookie right now
but um but i'm gonna go with properly
rated with premium whiskey
japanese whiskey pappy hard to get
single barrels
i'm gonna go with properly rated muffins
muffins are grossly underrated
i'm obsessed with muffins i'm about that
muffin life
and don't smile drock i'm a big corn
muffin guy
at the airport show me a blurry muffin
interesting carrot muffin good
card i think nascar is
underrated i think it's still
predominantly a regional sport
southern country it's made progress over
the last 25 years
it got super hot at one point in the
late 90s early 2000s it felt like it was
going to have its ufc soccer moment
it feels like it took a step back but
the community of passionate nascar fans
excite me mumble i think bumble's
underrated actually i love what they did
i thought that was a super smart
innovation
i loved that they gave one of the sexes
the leverage
i thought it was clever that was smart i
know several people
who have really preferred that platform
and i'm going to go with underrated
oreos i think oreos are properly rated
incredibly iconic brand very few brands
have done it better
extremely popular have expanded the
culturally relevant the supreme oreo
popped that up so smart i i say properly
rated because they are just so adored
um and just an incredible product top
tires
[Music]
i think pop tarts are underrated because
they're multi-dimensional drock
pop tarts are good cot pop tarts are
good cold
there's a lot of different pop tarts and
i think they're underrated i really do
drew bree
i have historically not been a fan of
drew brees i've always had this funny
like vibe towards him other than that he
like literally looks like a historically
nice guy
i've always liked this birthmark but
i've had this funny almost like
fake meme with my brother aj of not like
me not liking drew brees um he's had a
great career but i
i would argue drew b's is slightly
overrated he's amassed a lot he won a
super bowl it's huge over peyton manning
it's huge
but i'm gonna go with slightly overrated
hot challenge how hot
very hot showers well my skin is
sensitive so i can't go
all the way there but like a good hot
shower is pretty awesome i'm gonna say
that hot showers are
actually you know where i'm gonna go i'm
gonna go with hot showers slightly
overrated let me tell you why
it's cold showers that are underrated
even though i like a
solidly solidly warm shower
youtube i hope you enjoyed that episode
i love doing this for you thank you so
much for the community please check out
other episodes on the side
and please please please subscribe and
leave a comment
you